- - Chantal Hébert, bonsoir à vs
trtrois. Je remonte rapidement u
tatableau assez simple sur les
fafaits saillants. Déficit prévu
dede 52,8 milliards.
NoNon, le Canada ne veut pas
atatteindre les 2 % avec sa.
PrPremier tour de table rapide.n
enentrant à la Chambre des
cocommunes, Mme Freeland et
MoMonsieur Trudeau ont fait des
dédétours pour dire : vous save,
n'n'oubliez pas que ces
reresponsables, ce sera
reresponsable, ce sera
reresponsable. Chantal Hébert,
esest-ce que c'est un budget
reresponsable ou c'est un budget
dadavantage dépensier?
- - Bon, ça, c'est un jeu auquel
onon joue pour arriver à déjouer
leles attentes. Et clairement, e
bubudget-là déjoue les attentes
dadans le sens où le conservater
avavec leurs commentaires sur le
bubudget est irresponsable, avat
prpréparé le terrain. Au niveau
dedes communications, les libérx
sosont en train d'obtenir
exexactement les titres qu'ils
veveulent. Ça veut dire que quad
onon gère des attentes, ce budg-
llà aurait pu être écrit par des
coconservateurs avec l'appui du
NPNPD. En plus, M. Singh joue ds
çaça sans problème en disant
fifinal, ça va. C'est quand même
inintéressant.
- - Hélène, comme dit Chantal, l
y y avait un jeu des attentes, s
gegens s'attendaient un buffet
gagargantuesque. Oups, pas ça.
- - Je me suis demandé si c'état
unun hasard ou Mme Freeland état
enen bleu conservateur
auaujourd'hui. D'habitude, elle
esest toujours en rouge.
- - Faites attention, c'est pour
leles couleurs de l'Ukraine.
- - Mais quand même, il y avaitn
memessage. Les attentes étaient
trtrès élevées, mais à cause dea
cacampagne électorale, il y avat
bebeaucoup de problèmes dans cee
cacampagne pour 78 milliards por
totout un mandat, mais néanmoins
onon s'attendait à beaucoup de
dédépenses là-dedans. Plusieurs
d'd'entre elles n'y sont pas. Je
pepense à tout le volet de la
sasanté, il y était exposé d'avr
dedes milliards et ils ne sont s
auau rendez-vous, incluant ce pr
réréduire les liste d'attente ds
lele milieu des chirurgies. La
prpromesse des libéraux étaiente
dodonner tout de suite 6 millias
àà la première année et on est
plplutôt au tiers de ça avec 2
mimilliards. Bref, oui, c'est un
jejeu d'attente, mais on sent
ququ'il y a une certaine retenu.
OnOn nous a parlé pendant le hus
clclos pour nous dit qu'il y avt
bebeaucoup d'incertitudes à caue
dede l'inflation, à cause de la
guguerre en Ukraine, à cause des
chchangements climatiques. On st
ququ'on a voulu faire attention.
- - La mise à jour du gouvernemt
grgrâce à l'inflation a réussi à
enengendrer 36 milliards de plus
quque ce qu'on prévoyait. On n'n
dédépense seulement 5 milliards
cecette année. La marge de
mamanoeuvre de Freeland, elle ne
l'l'a pas utilisé en dépenses. n
avavait pu créer des programmes
avavec cette marge de manoeuvre.
MMême l'argent pour la défense,
cece n'est pas énorme contenu de
cece que l'OTAN demande est ce e
lala pression populaire demande
ététant donnée l'Ukraine. On a
vrvraiment été très prudent du
ccôté de Chrystia Freeland.
CeCe budget différent de ceux
auauxquels on était habitué avec
leles libéraux. Le programme de
sosoins dentaires, il faudra
nénégocier avec les provinces.
5 5 milliards de dollars sur ciq
anans, ce n'est pas un nouveau
prprogramme très coûteux comme
d'd'autres programmes comme les
gagarderies qui vont coûter une
fofortune. On est vraiment dans
dedes cibles tout à fait
raraisonnables. On dirait pas ls
lilibéraux de Justin Trudeau.
- - Dans quelle mesure, contenue
l'l'entente avec le NPD, on avat
papas besoin d'en faire autant,
jujustement? On se sentait plus
lilibre?
- - Deux choses : selon mes
cacalculs, c'est le premier budt
dedepuis 2008 au c'est pas un
bubudget endémique... un budget
papandémique. C'est le budget dn
gogouvernement qui sait acheteru
tetemps et qui ne pensent pas ac
leles an qui sera en campagne
élélectorale. Donc, toutes les
esespèces de filatures qu'on met
auautour des budget qu'en est
miminoritaire ne sont pas là. Dc
ilil y a moins de verbiage
totoujours bienvenu. Mais c'estn
gogouvernement qui se donne le
tetemps, et on a vu Monsieur Sih
ququi fait la même chose, le
cocontraire j'ai été étonnant
d'd'ailleurs. J'ai rarement vu n
bubudget où il y a autant de
fificelles attachées qu'ils ne e
sosont pas. C'est à peu près das
chchaque poste de dépenses.
- - Sur cette même question de
cecette liberté, du temps qu'on
s's'est donné grâce à l'entente,
çaça transparaît, effectivement,
lele mot classe moyenne ne revit
papas à chaque paragraphe.
- - Oui, on est très content que
lele budget ne fasse que quelqus
cecentaines de pages plutôt que
101000 comme la dernière fois,
c'c'était une sacrée brique. La
miministre l'a dit lui-même quad
onon lui a posé la question pour
lele prescrit aujourd'hui,
popourquoi toutes vos promesses
élélectorales ne s'y trouvent p?
ElElle a dit que c'était le
prpremier chapitre de quatre
chchapitres. Oui effectivement
l'l'entente avec le NPD lui pert
d'd'avoir plus de temps, et
jujustement de voir venir les
chchoses selon cette incertitude
quque l'on dit figurer à
l'l'horizon. Il manque beaucoupe
dédétails sur plusieurs mesures.
JeJe pense à la réforme sur
l'l'assurance emploi. On nous dt
quque ça s'en vient, on nous dit
ququ'il y aura des consultations
etet quand les consultations
seseront terminées, on déposeran
plplan. Ça a nous donne aucune e
dede quand c'est, ça. On nous ns
didit pas comment faire ça, mais
onon nous dit que ce sera cette
anannée. Cela nous amène à pensr
quque on va fonctionner seulemet
papar crédit d'impôt. Vous allez
enenvoyer votre part d'impôt por
pepeut-être obtenir un retour, e
ququi éviterait des champs marie
avavec les provinces...
- - j'y reviens à ça, après.
- - Enverra parce que celle-ci
c'c'est comme ça qu'on procède,
leles familles moins nanties à i
s's'adresse programme, ça ne rèe
papas nécessairement le problème
paparce que dans le cabinet du
dedentiste, vous ne répétez pas
leles 200 $ ou 300 $ nécessaire.
- - Ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'n'avait pas vu un budget qui
reressemble à un budget. On ne
pepeut pasas plaire à tout le m,
auaux voisins, à l'autre, il y a
ququelque chose de plus simple t
pepeut-être de plus direct?
- - C'est un budget de
gogouvernement majoritaire. Ça
trtransparaît dans la manière dt
lele gouvernement. Est-ce qu'ona
êêtre capable de le mettre en
plplace l'assurance dentaire jee
susuis pas certain. C'est très
vavariable d'une province à
l'l'autre pour les soins
dedentaires. Au Québec, pour les
enenfants de moins de 10 ans c't
prpresque la gratuité totale,
alalors qu'en Ontario ça va
jujusqu'à 17 ans.
IlIl doit il va y avoir de
l'l'arrimage avec les provinces
popour que ce soit plus uniform.
EsEst-ce qu'on envoie un chèqueà
QuQuébec? On calcule à peu près1
mimilliard par année. J'ai de vr
sisi la facture finale va
reressembler à ça. Il y en a
plplusieurs comme ça qui pourrat
vavarier le coût, mais on a la
mamarge de manoeuvre. On est
cacapable de s'ajuster.
- - 12 milliards de plus de préu
ququ'il y a six mois. Qu'est-ce
quque ça vous dit sur les
nénégociations avec les provincs
dede cet énoncé budgétaire?
- - Ça va être un grand classiqe
: : il va y avoir des provinces
ququi vont se battre plus
fafarouchement que d'autres pour
avavoir l'autonomie. On va voulr
l'l'argent, comme avec les
gagarderies, on va demander quee
sosoit sans condition. Si la
cacampagne électorale fédérale..
cece ne sera pas aussi bien
didisposé qu'au Québec.
- - Plus généralement, sur cette
dedemande des provinces de montr
àà 38 %?
- - Ah oui, sur la santé, ça va
prprendre négociations séparéesn
bobonne et due forme. Ça va
vrvraiment prendre une ronde de
nénégociation assez serrée. Et a
ququ'ils n'obtiendront pas les 8
mimilliards de dollars qu'il
réréclame. On annonçait un plan
plplus généreux aujourd'hui pare
quque les provinces vont recevor
plplus d'argent. Ça va prendre
nénégociations.
- - J'ai un peu l'impression que
ceces batailles avec les provins
sosont rapportées à un peu plus
tatard justement un peu à causee
totout ce qu'on dit auparavant,à
sasavoir que les dépenses étaiet
ciciblées pour recruter des
mémédecins, la santé mentale, ls
sosoins à longue durée. Ces
dédépenses placeront probablemet
dadans le chapitre deux ou le
chchapitre trois. Pour l'instan,
onon ne voit pas nécessairemente
prprogramme qui nécessite de
hahautes négociations. Sur la
ququestion du transfert en santé
ququi n'est pas haussé, quand me
inintéressant de noter que danse
bubudget on parle de 4,3 %. Ce
n'n'est pas si parce qu'on est
plplus généreux, c'est simplemet
ququ'on applique la formule de
crcroissance et ça adonne parce
ququ'il y a de la croissance ete
l'l'inflation que ça fait monter
lele transfert. Comme tel, il ny
a a aucun gain pour les provincs
enen ce moment.
- - Ça été... pour la défense,
esest-ce que là encore, il y avt
lele jeu des attentes qu'il y en
avavait moins que ce qu'on avait
pupu croire?
- - Un petit point sur la santé,
ququand même. Monsieur Trudeau t
fafavorisé par le fait que
élélections notariaux, élections
enen Québec, il ne rencontrera s
vrvraiment les provinces indécis
avavant la fin de l'automne
prprochain. C'est le calendrier
ququi dit ça. Sur la défense, ce
ququ'il y avait de plus
inintéressant dans le budget
n'n'avait pas rien à voir avec e
bubudget, c'est-à-dire qu'on va
fafaire une révision de la
popolitique canadienne en matièe
dede défense, ce qu'on n'a pas
fafait depuis des lunes. Le mone
a a changé et on n'a jamais
ajajusté. On n'a jamais réajusté
nonos priorités. Avant de se
lalancer dans des immenses
dédépenses, ce serait bien de
sasavoir comment on vovoit notre
dédéfense dans l'univers de la
guguerre en Ukraine, etc.
- - ça c'est bien de savoir ce
ququ'on veut faire avant d'acher
dedes choses qui coûtent très
chcher.
- - Vous savez, il n'y a pas si
lolongtemps, on parlait de
teterrorisme, c'est à ça qu'on
vovoulait préparer l'armée
cacanadienne. Ce n'est pas une
guguerre comme on a vu depuis la
seseconde guerre mondiale. On na
papas pensé qu'on peut dépenser
cocomme les Américains pour des
avavions, des sous-marins, des
chchars d'assaut. Ce serait bien
dede dessiner quelque chose dans
cece sens-là. Et que les autres
papartis d'opposition pour qu'on
ararrête à chaque fois qu'on
chchange de parti de changer de
popolitique de défense. À
tetellement d'argent, ces
acacquisitions la, que si on
rerecommence à chaque syndicat,
c'c'est normal quelque chose
dédéraille. On veut quelque choe
dede moins partisan. Dans la
réréflexion, ça pourrait être
inintéressant.
- - Le luxe du temps, le pouvoir
veveut prendre le temps de
réréfléchir avant d'agir, un mot
ququand même sur Bay du Nord, e-
cece qu'on a l'extrait... on va
écécouter Monsieur Guilbault qui
nonous disait, on le sentait, on
nene peut pas mentir à ce point,
ilil n'était pas à l'aise.
STSTEVEN GUILBEAULT, ministre
féfédéral de l'Environnement
- - C'est une décision qui était
évévidemment très difficile, coe
onon a à en prendre, hélas souvt
ququand on dirige un pays de
3737 millions de personnes.
CeCela étant, nous avons,
nonous nous sommes engagés quand
nonous avons réformé le processs
d'd'évaluation environnementale,
dede le dépolitiser. C'est
exexactement ce que nous avons
fafait avec l'évaluation
enenvironnementale. Et là, j'ai
unun groupe d'experts qui a étué
lele projet pendant quatre ans t
ququi m'a fait une recommandatin
enen disant que; nous, on estime
quque le projet n'a pas d'impact
sisignificatif.
- - Un tour de table rapide, es-
cece que c'est un boulet qu'ils
vovont traîner, oui ou non?
- - Probablement moins parce que
lele timing en politique, ça
cocompte. On est à un moment oùn
esest préoccupé par la
l'l'augmentation des cas de COV,
lala guerre en Ukraine. La preu,
c'c'est qu'on en parle à la toue
fifin.
(r(rires)
- - je suis certain que Monsieur
GuGuilbault n'était pas content
d'd'avoir à faire cette annonce.
S'S'il savait et que de lui, il
n'n'aurait pas accepté ce proje.
C'C'était écrit dans le ciel que
cece projet allait être adapté
paparce qu'il est beaucoup moins
popolluant que les autres projes
pépétroliers au Canada. Par
exexemple, on dit que dans
l'l'intensité c'est 10 fois mois
popolluant Barrie pour Barrie qe
leles sables bitumineux. Alors
didirent non à ce projet auraiet
étété envoyés le message que
dédésormais, plus aucun projet e
pépétroliers ne sera accepté au
CaCanada je sais bien que les
enenvironnementalistes, c'est ce
ququ'il demande, mais on ne peut
papas augmenter la production,
alalors que les émissions se
ststabilisent. Monsieur Guilbaut
n'n'est sûrement pas compte, mas
c'c'est une décision qui se défd
cocontenue de e la position libe
ququi aide quand même défendre
l'l'industrie pétrolière pour ue
trtransition.
- - Certainement dans cette
dédécision se, ça pèse.
ReRemplacer les sables bituminex
ququi sont plus polluants, on le
feferait, ce n'est pas ça qui va
sese produire... hier, c'est paé
ininaperçu, mais au même moment
StSteven Guilbeault a dit non àn
auautre projet. Il y a là un
esespèce d'équilibre qu'on chere
àà avoir qui paraît pas toujours
trtrès bien parce que là, on n't
papas un nouveau projet. Mais ds
lele fond peut-être que cet
écéchange va sur le long terme
vavaut la peine. Oui, ça va